guys you have one more day to get this
merch and then it's gone forever one
more guys that's right do you want some
official trash taste merch t-shirts long
sleeves hoodies buttonup jackets you
only have 24 hours to pre-order it
before it's gone forever hours trash
taste. shop links in the description
once it's gone it's gone forever you
heard the warning do it right now click
that link in the description it people
who watch football are almost like
professional Watchers of of sports what
what are you what are you talking about
reaction Chanel people who people who go
to watch League of Legends are not
really Stadium
goers welcome back to another episode of
trash taste I'm joined once again by the
boys joang hello episode 180
180 that's scary to say so close to 200
now yes this is a topical episode we're
coming to you fresh from TR well me and
Connor just came back from Korea we uh
wanted to talk about it I guess please
your what do you think on it was your
first time so uh it was cool it swag and
that's the end of trash guys
thanks it was uh it was nice uh a lot of
things I liked some things I didn't like
as much you know well let's let's run
through it what did you like what did
you not like okay okay I I I got to
together I got to get this he's going to
tell me I I got to come out all right
it's Str sh I got to come out swinging
because I was I think I've mentioned
this take before and now I've been to
Korea another times uh like more times
now I genuinely believe that Korean
barbecue is better in the states yeah
like I I have gone to three different
Korean barbecue places in Korea now and
they've I've always not so much been
disappointed but more so I've gone to
them and I'm like this is good but I
felt like my experience I I was like I
know what Peak is and Peak is like
Korean barbecue in LA and I think I also
agree with you on that like it's not to
say that Korean barbecue is bad
necessarily it's fantastic ftic but like
I don't know what it is is it the cuts
of the meat is it the way they cook it
is it the marinade I don't know what it
is but there's just something about the
meat they use in American Korean
barbecue that is just it just is more
pleasing to my
palette and I don't know why I I like
all you can eat I'm I like all you can
eat and in Korea a lot of them were not
all you can eat true yeah I mean there
there were there are a lot of O can eat
uh Queen Barbecues in Korea but I feel
like I don't know sometimes like the
Vibe is different because you get it it
almost felt like every Korean barbecue
place I went to there was less choice of
like the different cuts three Cuts in
this one place I went to that was it it
was like pork only three yeah they
specialized in like those cuts and it
was fine it was pretty good yeah what
what the thing I see in Korean barbecues
in Korea is very much more it's more
reminiscent of like the Yaki Yaki niku
kind of experience where you have these
like very specialized CS yeah it's kind
of I would almost say Korean barbecue in
Korea is kind of like the in between of
Japanese Yaki niku and like American
cream barbecue if that makes sense like
there's elements to Yaki niku where it's
like the meat cuts are more specialized
as you said but it also is I guess a lot
more I don't want to say flavorful like
American Korean barbecue but like what
what's the word like you know what I
mean like it's it's when you eat Yaki
niku it's heavy for sure because you're
eating a shitload of meat but like it
doesn't leave you with that feeling of
like oh God kind of deal you know no I'd
win huh i' I'd win every time I win I
don't get that feeling when I when I
have the meats yeah no meat makes you
feel light it's like stop what when I
eat a [__] ton of meat I feel
good what do you mean what is this like
controversial taste yes yes I feel way
worse if I have like a Ramen well yeah
because you're eat that's like starch
and uh salt yeah well obviously but like
how do you not feel like like it's not
so much like okay cuz like when you eat
ramen it's the kind of like feel feel of
full where it's you're bloated right
obviously because you've had a lot of
starch you've had a lot of carbs and
then you you know and then the noodles
obviously expand in your stomach when
you have you know the ramen like broth
and like water and stuff like that right
but with meat it's just it's a lot it is
a lot of food I've never been to a
Korean barbecue in America at least and
I have like especially if it's all you
can eat and you get to a point where you
know okay here's here's the big question
here's his the big question do you order
rice you go to an or you can heat place
you can order as much meat as you can do
you order rice I try to stay away from
it yeah I try to only meet the system so
normally i' normally I'd try to get a
little bit of rice but most of the time
when I go to an or you can eat Korean
barbecue place I eat only meat I eat a
[__] lot of rice and you get to that
point because it works well with the
rice that's the whole point how they get
you no no that's okay that's like going
to like he call me niin I like my rice
that's that's like going to a buffet and
having the pizza crust when you have
like all you can eat pizza that's just
like
spacee that first of all I eat the cross
because I'm not a [__] child no okay
especially in an all you can eat fake
crust is just empty like crust is just
wasted stomach space I swear to okay
we're not we're not going to end your
baby opinion on that let's let's stay on
topic right okay staying on topic you
eat enough meat and I remember like you
just get like the meat sweats do you
guys know what I'm talking about you
guys know what I'm talking about I get
like I get a little bit of that but I
don't get it that bad and I kind of like
that you like the meat sweats like
sweating when I eat
meat wait hold on it's satisfying do you
did you have to say it like that yes yes
I did I like sweating when I eat meat I
like sweating when I'm gobling down
meat because I I always enjoy the
feeling of just eating a [__] ton of
meat but I always regret it the moment I
walk outside why do you regret it
because it's just a lot of [__] meat
yeah but that's it's just a lot man no
that's not a regret and and then when
the sweats start kicking in you're just
like oh God what I only regret that I
had weakness and I and I had to stop I
wanted to keep
going why are you laughing I'm serious
really funny imagining you step out of a
koream barbecue sweating your knots off
and you're like damn that feels good I
know I like I like it cuz that means I
ate a good amount of meat [__] you know
you don't like that no okay I don't I
don't say I don't like it obviously I I
love eating meat pause but I don't like
the feeling that you get after you've
had like a shitload of meat you know
like there's there's a there's a good
amount of meat you can have where you
feel satisfied and you don't get the
sweats you know but when you go to a
Korean barbecue or even a Yakiniku I
never not have that because the option
to have as much meat as you possibly can
is more satisfying okay I don't know
this is thing when I go to Yakiniku you
if it's like or you can order or you can
eat I always you can
order if you can say it you can well
that's 20 plates I'm not going to eat
any oh that's that's how I think about
it because I don't know why I always
come out of Yaki n and I feel like I've
eaten like I I get like reasonably full
even if even if it's all you can eat for
some reason when I go to Korean barbecue
I always [__] stuff myself to the
Limit and as you should I think that's
just a personal taste issue though I
don't know why I think you just prefer
Korean barbecue over Yakiniku yeah I
mean also in Japan when you when you get
to Yakiniku a lot of the times the
portions are quite small so even when
you're ordering of meat quite small so
it's really hard to actually just get
through it cuz they're bringing it quite
slowly odds are you're eating it way
faster than they're bringing it out yeah
I think that's the big thing I like
about America as well when you when you
order a portion of meat they give you
they slap down an entire [__] massive
PL sometimes though and I just feel bad
for wasting it cuz I look at this like
leftover pile of I'm sweating just
dripping that's where the meat I have to
eat that some places in America do this
though they charge you if you don't eat
uh some some of the meat yeah you do
that thing where you kind of put it all
put it on the grill you're like H maybe
it'll like disintegrate in the corner
you're like it's like if I Char it down
enough and I shove it down put it on
this thing no no that's the Strat when
uh that's not with like Korean barbecue
but hot pot that's like if you go if you
can all if you go to an or you can eat a
hot pot you're like [__] how do we get
rid of all of the [__] that we ordered
uh I mean meat kind of like crank the
heat up meat shrinks if you leave
long enough right oh by the way merch oh
yeah yeah yeah I mean we obviously said
it at the beginning of the episode but
hey we got M we said at the beginning we
said at the beginning of the episode we
did that [__] all right yeah we said but
we can shout it out again check it out I
I could eat a lot of meat in this and
comfortable it is stretchy it is
stretchy insane quality you went crazy
yeah I wanted to thank uh Joey for this
one because he handled this merch drop
this is crazy yeah available for limited
time as we mentioned Link in the
description yeah it's so com
I'm glad you can finally see wearing
something else sweats now you get to
meat sweats just thinking about it think
about it but I also I also think another
thing about Korean barbecue that I enjoy
in America as well um is I don't know if
this is just the barbecue places that I
went to in career as well but I feel
like they have different like bogis and
galves that they give you as well
there's just so much more different
choices not only of the cuts one day
I'll figure out what bulgogi is
isn't it just Mar isn't it just the name
of a marinade I don't know I don't
know there's just there's just every
kind of combination of all the sources
and all the cuts that you can think of
in America and in Korea it's just very
at least from my experience very very
much more limited maybe it was just the
places I went to but it was three
different places I went we also had
fried chicken one night and it was
pretty bad I think we went to a bad
place yeah I think that was just the
place that we went went to so me and
Sydney actually walked past that place
and I didn't notice this so we stayed in
uh hondai was it it was like very
tourist very touristy so I think we just
went to a tourist trap because
definitely we definitely did yeah yeah
because I I had uh fried chicken with
Sydney like afterwards is where I stayed
for a few more days and it [__]
slapped it was it was great um but I I
did I walked past the place that me and
Connor went to and I saw it
um because we ate here on the very first
day we literally just landed we were
just like let's go to a chicken place
found the first chicken place sure like
the only place I could fit like a big
roof right right and I saw they had a
sign and I didn't and now I know this is
a guaranteed tourist trap right cuz I I
saw it had a sign and it said Gordon
Ramsey recommends this chicken place and
I was just like no [__] way Gordon
Ramsey actually recommends this
particular chicken place
Emily accidentally ordered like five
times the amount of chicken we needed
why did she do this every time so
literally they it was like it was like
the a meme it just kept coming out we we
had like and it wasn't even that good
yeah yeah we had like we had like like
30 pieces of chicken left over and I was
like Emily why did you order this much
she's like why didn't they tell me this
was too much I was like I feel like the
onus is on you here Emily not them yeah
it was great because uh you know the
only person who could speak just a
little bit of Korean was Emily so we
kind of just left everything to her yeah
how is it the one person that can speak
the language [__] up
the she was over over she she
overestimated because she was expecting
Japanese portions uh but we soon found
out that Japanese portions and Korean
portions are very very very different
never Chang um and then we you know we
had like 30 more pieces of chicken then
we could possibly eat and then we were
we went to a craft fair Place afterwards
and we were just like let's order a
pizza as well cuz we're on holiday did
you get the meat sweats uh we got the
pizza sweats the pizza swe we like okay
okay Emily Emily we would like to order
the small size of the pizza and like a
[__] meme somehow something got Lost
in Translation and they brought out the
biggest size of the pizza 18 in it was
an 18
in was like Emily come
on what the [__] when when do you
realize that you she might purpose be
doing this maybe just to [__] with you
guys so yeah that was that was that was
kind of just like a what the [__] day
one food was kind of mid so it was like
all right well hopefully be better and
it was better the rest of the food that
we had was although I Korean Hot Dogs
worst worst hot dog experience in my
life why would you go to cre to have a
hot dog well cuz we were in the stadium
watching League of Legends okay and I
thought that a must that I do I I like
to do this everywhere I like to get a
hot dog everywhere I go so I want to you
know it's a it's a staple everywhere you
go in the world I love how that's your
bench mark everywhere cuz CU you know
it's just interesting thator Koreans
every single country has a different
like take on it sure so I wanted to try
it and uh it looked like a ketchup and
mustard on the sign okay I was like I'll
take one of those uh and I hand it to me
and there's sweet corn on it just sweet
corn and like and then it was like
ketchup but if ketchup was four times
sweeter right uh and some other weird
relish and then I I look at the meat and
it's just like white I was like what the
[__] why is my hot dog White yeah uh and
I confirm looking at the picture it was
meant to look like a normal hot dog sure
I B into it worst hot dog in my life it
was terrible it like flaked apart it was
brittle it fell apart like like uh
cement on you why is on me I'm going to
put that on you I gotg from a stadium
because you were you got a hot dog from
a stadium because you were probably and
in a country that doesn't specializing
hot dogs okay first of all I it doesn't
matter if the country specializing hot
dogs right I every stadium sells hot
dogs and I like testing each Stadium's
hot dogss okay uh and some countries do
it good UK does not do it good have you
had Japanese Stadium hot dogs before uh
no I still haven't I've never been to a
Japanese Stadium they suck I will be the
judge of that don't even bother they
suck com war in Korea [__] brittle
ass hot dog sweet corn sweet corn of a
hot dog in what year to be fair that is
whack but like wild what was what was
the rest of the stadium menu like it was
like fried chicken it great wish this is
like what you should be getting I didn't
want fried chicken I had the fried
chicken I had like they have the Korean
like street food which like they peel
the whole potato and put on the the the
spiral potato tornado potato no it's
[__] dumb I don't want give me French
fries you know what the [__] why do I
have to get this comically large stick
no you know what's dumb buying a hot dog
in because they put [__] sugar on
everything in Korea as well yeah and
they're probably going to do it on the
hot dog which they did they did and also
on the [__]
the potato which is french fries they
put sugar on it why because they do that
everywhere I want salt on did you go to
have you been to a Korean bakery before
no but I presume they just put sugar
dude it is like eating sugar if it was
in carb form it is so incredibly sweet
also I got Pringles one
day I wanted oh yeah let's let's talk
about all the Korean things I did in in
Korea listen I had Pringles one day
right the Korean St I was craving I was
craving some God damn real crisps right
I wanted some [__] salty ass crisps
cuz everything was [__] sweet in
Korea and I was getting [__] sick of
it so I go I go to the [__]
Pringles I'm pleading to like the
[__] Monopoly man or whoever it is on
the front the Pringle man the guy with
the mustache I'm like please I beg of
thee give me something salty I need to
have some salt in my veins and I I look
at the options I have like sour cream
and onion uh there's cheese something
else and there's there's a hot very hot
it says okay so I get the spicy one I'm
like yeah [__] it it's going to be spicy
yeah I [__] I open it up and I look
at it it's like it's like pink I like
that's weird yeah I eat it it's just
[__] sweet it's not spicy at all you
had one right it was just sweet I was so
pissed off how did they do that it was
it was black the the the
universal explanation for spicy things
is black packaging also in a country
like Korea where there's a lot of
[__] spicy it to be spicy black and
red packaging they had jalapenos on it
is cut in half this was supposed to be
it this supposed to be spicy suppos to
be salty I bite into it it's like a
light jalapeno that's been drenched in
Sugar can you look the package I want to
see this packaging yeah can you can you
type in h Korean Pringles hot flavor or
something maybe maybe hot in Korean
means like sweet
H not no no no I mean it's that flavor
right um but it is it is that exact
flavor you know because I've seen that
flavor before in
Pringles
uh yeah I think it is that flavor which
one no it's the black one the black one
is like hot and
spicy and I was like oh thank God I get
to finally have a [__] kick and it's
[__] sweet so I was I was getting
that was the one thing that was pissing
me off of our career actually everything
was sweet I had miso soup one day I was
like great that's how you know you're
really clutching at straws in
Korea salt in your body I I had I had uh
I I ordered a My Boy hasn't had a single
Korean meal in no no I went to a b and
bar restaurant right it was [__]
Godlike it it was amazing it was it
Korea so so good it was literally this
small shop run by one dude he was doing
everything uh and I had to wait like 10
minutes to get in but it was [__]
amazing it was so worth it and it was
really like it was just amazing but on
the side he brought miso soup with it
and I was like great I get to have
something salty sure I pick it up I have
a sip it's
sweet I think they put you serious yeah
I think they put sugar or something in
the Miso soup it was sweet okay that as
a Japanese person I am definitely a fan
this is where I literally I I I I sipped
it and I
went what
like thank you so much oh this is oat
milk this
is I just took a zp don't worry it's
okay oh [__] oh no oh god oh Jesus oh
sorry sorry I SC everywhere oh my God
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'll take one
as well okay so yeah I I was I was just
getting that was the only thing that was
kind of annoying me about career it you
just weren't getting a JB with the food
no no I I had I had great food in Korea
generally uh be bar was definitely the
Highlight that but then when you Tred to
redeem yourself with the previous meal
you just got worse yeah yeah and then
like I feel like the best meals I had in
ker was the stuff that you was is harder
to get of like outside of Korea sure
like Korean barbecu is everywhere you
know um Fried Chicken everywhere as well
uh which there were plenty of good fried
chicken places in Korea but it's very
much a case of hey if you go to the
popular touristy places it's still you
know just because it's Fried Chicken
just because it's Korean barbecue
doesn't mean the quality is going to
suddenly increase just because you're in
career did you have any of like the
street food yeah we did we had a street
food day it was pretty good but it felt
like cuz all of the stores were like the
same they were literally all like just
copy paste stores it just kind of felt
like it was like I don't know that it
wasn't like what's the what's the word
you kind of hope it's just like one dude
who's like I just make a sick [__]
noodles it was more like there's an Oreo
truck and there's 15 of them and then
there's the same truck that sells the
exact same meat and it's all the same it
kind of felt like a little more
corporate I think kind of like it wasn't
there was there were some individual
stores and there was one that did like
some black bean noodles that were pretty
good that was really nice I think I
think from from my experience of going
to like a lot of like street food stuff
in Korea like the the biggest like
selling point of it is not necessarily
like this store specialized than this or
this store specializing in this it's
like you just pick a place that you can
kind of vibe with the owner of that
store with just kind of like sit down
and just chill with the dude while
having a nice meal I think that's like
the biggest thing it's not like Japan
where it's like if you want the takak
you got to go to this place if you want
the [__] orom Yaki you got to go to
this place it's like just I think like
you know cuz unlike Japan uh I feel
Koreans in general are a lot more just
like open to like stranger friendliness
yeah yeah like to yeah Korean people are
so so [__] cool so friendly
especially on this trip I definitely
notti started noticing the difference
more between Japanese culture and Korean
uh let's I don't know how I didn't
notice this the first time but holy [__]
drivers are
crazy they are insane I I'd forgotten
because I thought Japanese taxi drivers
were sometimes you you'd find an insane
taxi driver in Japan I was like the
worst the most insane taxi driver in
Japan is the most sane taxi driver in
Korea every single taxi is like this oh
yeah dude oh my God but you know I I
I've been complaining a lot about this
the sweetness of the food but it was
really really fun and I I I really like
career a lot uh I definely want to go
back and I I got that feeling again of
being completely useless in the country
yeah cuz I don't speak any Korean and I
was like a [__] dud you know what was
the most annoying part because I didn't
know any Korean I always defaulted to
Japanese and it was like [__] muscle
memory I kept saying hi and da your
boots everything even though I was just
like wait [__] I'm yeah I I would say hi
a lot I had to catch myself yeah sees an
Asian imately says hi I'm like [__] am I
being racist right now I'm I swear to
God I swear I'm not mistaking you for
Japanese I this is just muscle memory
right now that that's going on I I felt
like bad that I I couldn't speak much
Korean I was like man I feel like I
should should be better but also it's
like I was only there for a weekend yeah
we were only there for a weekend and I
like I I you know I I learned the word
for yes and that was pretty much it
thank
you that button I was like thank you
thank you just need a
sound no B massive L um except in our
hotel we had Beday oh yeah it was like
50/50 for me some bars had Beday way uh
and some bars didn't they're getting it
they're getting there slowly I
appreciate it yeah I prefer some Bay to
no B days so yeah I think if I I
definitely want to go back maybe like
next year because it's just so godamn
close like a 2hour flight one thing that
caught me off guard and this is cuz I've
just been in Japan too long is that
people would just randomly spit
occasionally yeah and like obviously
people spit in Japan but you you just
don't see it at all um so yeah could you
imagine fun fact nobody spits in
Japan yeah it was just really Weir it
was super jarring because you're like
you know you Japan and Korea they they
they have a lot of similar uh Vibes at
times and then the dude just goes and
you're like oh wow okay wow yeah this is
different they have a lot of
similarities to Japan but then you also
figure out Korea is right next to China
so they take a lot of their like
cultural like I guess uniquenesses from
China as well cuz like I I mean I've
never been to China but I've heard from
people who living China and friends from
China that like I've been to China a lot
of people like just spit in the streets
it's next like if you go on public
transport there uh at least like when I
went to China which was quite a long
time ago now uh but they you know you go
on a bus or you go on a plane or
something and people will literally have
spit bags yeah I've seen these yeah
yeah and that's just a bit like too much
of a level for me to be like
the are like that's a little too much
we'll just do it on the road yeah yeah
yeah uh but but like uh it was really
nice they had a lot of cool craft beer
places that's what I normally go to when
I'm yeah like to me I think like okay
comparing like Japan to Korea I think
Japan uh as a whole the quality of like
food is like you know higher in Japan in
my opinion in my personal opinion if you
go to a random restaurant it's probably
going to be always slaps you know if you
go to Korea you there are plenty of
amazing [__] restaurants there but
there can be some mid places as well
that you stumble
into but drinking and the drinking
culture in career I think is way more
fun and oh it's next level yeah yeah
yeah that's that's that's what ker has
the advantage in I wonder if there
because this is something I struggled
with when I was there and I was thinking
I'm like man I I know where to go in
Japan to get all the the things I like
and all the good food and I and I know
what to look for and I I it was kind of
like starting from zero where I was like
I don't know what to look for and I'm
sure that I would probably say the
opposite if I lived in Korea for a long
time I came to Japan I'd be like yeah
but I just think Korea is more
consistent cuz Japan you can have some
really [__] food um there's a lot of you
know if you go to uh I wouldn't
necessarily say [__] but like definitely
underwhelming you can get yeah if you
just go to really bad eakas a lot you
can get some really like pretty pretty
awful food and I feel like I don't know
I I feel like it's hard for me to
properly figure out how it would be and
judge the two I don't know cuz I
remember when I visited Japan this
before we moved here like every meal
life I thought was [__] banger but
was that because was that because your
perspective of Japan at the time was
kind of like oh there's no place in
Japan that can miss you you might have
had you might have been looking at the
country and the culture through these
Rose tinted glasses and being like Oh
well I mean people will say this is mid
but I think it's fantastic kind of thing
you knowz there's a lot of people who do
that okay you know you know how you know
how I know you know how I know this is
this is the real test sure you do the
Comin test all right Japan companies
solos Korean comanies like oh that's
true easy easy you know and you know I
feel like for the most basic food I feel
like you know basic comedy food I feel
like some of that quality translates
into the restaurants that you get as
well I I'm trying to look at this as
unbiased as I can but I you know what
what do you want to say Conor no no no
go ahead I I'm put my hand up to say
I'll talk yeah I'm trying to look at
this as unbiased as I can but my memory
for coming to visit Japan was I was
never disappointed you know even if like
the only thing that has changed is my
perception of what the top tier food is
in Japan I actually liked food less when
I was a tourist here I I didn't like
food much when I was visiting here the
first time really yeah I I I I think
it's cuz my diet was so [__] British
that I think it was like it was it was a
shock to it's too Oriental for me I I
think gen genuinely like I and like it's
[__] stupid but like I I can also it
makes me kind of like sympathize bit
when people come to Japan and and I
appreciate they're trying to eat the
food but I know they're not vibing with
it cuz sometimes it just takes a little
bit of what like exposure to it takes a
little while for you to get used to it
yeah like I remember that I always I
always really really wanted to like
sushi and I just I just pretended every
single time well I remember you told us
like you know when you were growing up
in Wales like rice was seen as like a a
luxury or like a delicacy right no it
was not a luxury but more of like a a
kind of rice yeah it's like oh wow rice
okay a curry yeah and if it if if it it
wasn't for like Indian curry I don't
think I'd ever eat rice right um just
just not in the like Diet but I remember
the first time I had sushi I I really
really really wanted to like sushi cuz I
felt like I was kind of a weave I was
like I want like I think I would eat I
would eat all these cuts of sushi and I
remember thinking like yeah it's okay
yeah it's fine so the first few times I
had it I was like man I just don't
really Vibe with sushi but then after
living here after like a year I would
just start getting these cravings for
sushi and I was like oh I guess I just I
[__] with this thing now but I think
that's just cuz I've you're climatized
to it now right yeah and I think my my
taste pods are slowly changing and I'm
getting older but also I'm getting more
used to the food here I think it just it
just takes a while sometimes you to like
swap oh totally there are some agre
cases where people just it pisses me off
when no one tries like if you don't try
to eat anything but I can understand
when people have kind of a hard time
getting used to trying new
foods I mean there is a thing called
acquired taste you know like you have to
get your body kind of used to this like
new Sensational taste or whatever it is
right yeah I just ate a lot of heavier
food so I remember when I was here the
first week or so I was like man I just
want something that is [__] heavy I
want something that gives me the sweats
yeah cuz everything everything was very
light and I was like man I just miss
having that heavy feeling and now I'm
kind of I've swapped now I'm kind of in
the the Japan Camp of food I'm like I
actually don't want to feel heavy most
of the time but it's just weird how my
how that changes and I guess it's just
something we don't consider when we're
talking about Foods because we always at
each other's throats about crusts and
whatnot but
yeah I mean like I I think one of the
big reasons I really like you know
Korean food in general and one of the
things that I got when I in this career
trip compared to Japanese food is that
they know how to do spicy food and some
of my favorite meals when on this trip
was when some spice was involved because
my BL cheeks were hurting holy [__] I
had like I I remember we when me and cdy
went to this place I think it was like a
duck gby Place uh where they B basically
awful for your diet probably just like
spicy chicken and then you had like a
bunch of Che melted cheese on the side
and uh you you know you have the chicken
and then you can like plop it on the
cheese and it's like [__] Godlike it
was in like a cast iron like Skillet as
well that's the [__] they and that's how
you know and that's that's where that's
you get the meat and the cheese sweats
from that and then after you eat enough
the chicken they pour like some fried
rice on it and then they put like put a
bunch of spicy sauce so good yeah yeah
then and then they kind of like fry the
rice on the sket and then they put a
bunch of cheese on the rice put the rice
on the cheese so that you just put a
spoonful in and you get like some spicy
rice fried rice chicken and cheese it's
like a ricey lasagna and oh my God uh I
was I was on the toilet for a full day
but it was so worth it it was so godamn
there some bag of cheese darkby places
in Japan as like in in
um yeah oh my God uh also another thing
that career has figured out and I have
no idea why this hasn't caught on in the
in the the stadium right when you wanted
the beer you didn't get it in like an
open uh plastic cup you got a 1 lit like
uh soda bottle filled with beer and then
the woman goes how many cups do you want
I was like oh [__] I mean uh I'll get di
four yeah so we could all just pour each
other beers and then just close the lid
that's super SM I was like wait this is
genius why have we not why is the rest
of the world not doing this maybe
because it creates more waste uh
possibly but I don't think waste is a
concern of stadiums I think I I feel
like maybe they just sell more beer if
it's an if they everyone has to drink I
don't know or maybe it's because like
you know because Korea is such a heavy
drinking culture right like they
probably just think to themselves like
oh one cup is not going to be enough if
I'm going to carry like four cups to
myself I'd rather just get a full leader
bottle right well it's nice cuz we all
didn't have to like go and carry drinks
like one of us could just go get like
two bottles and we could all just share
the that's probably what it yeah I mean
that was I guess the q's probably this
episode is sponsored by expressvpn guys
I'm struggling it's the that time of the
year again it's is Christmas and I don't
know what to get my loved one for
Christmas a [__] I get it man I totally
get it I know exactly what you can get
people for Christmas what expressvpn oh
my God that's right expressvpn is an app
that lets you change your online
location this lets you trick websites
like Netflix for example into giving you
a whole new library of content because
if you didn't know Netflix has different
shows in every single country so for
example the whole week we've been using
expressvpn to binge the office on UK
Netflix because it's not really
available in Japan and I want some of
that Nostalgia you feel me it's so
simple to do I just fire up expressvpn
app on my computer or TV change my
location to the UK at refresh Netflix
and that's it it's that simple it lets
you choose from almost 100 different
countries so imagine all of the Netflix
libraries you can get throughout the
world but gentlemen it's not just
Netflix VPN helps you access more
content on all streaming services Disney
plus BBC I player YouTube you name it
they can do it too much and on top of
that xpn is so godamn fast it's so fast
there's never any buffering or lag and
it streams all the shows I like in HD so
if you're sick of all the cheesy shows
on Netflix this holiday season gift
yourself a brand new library of content
go to expressvpn.com traste right now
and you can get an extra 3 months of
expressvpn for free 3 months 3 months
that's expressvpn.com trast
expressvpn.com traste to learn more oh
we we watched League of Legends that I
guess I guess we didn't uh say that but
we went to watch uh the world
championship for League of Legends which
we were planning this trip first one the
first one first one yeah the first that
one that one that's literally what it
looks like that's smart it literally
comes like that yeah I know I don't know
why morum don't do that but yeah we went
to Korea to watch The League of Legends
World final uh which we had been
planning for a while and we actually
tried to go as a little uh we we tried
to get normal tickets at first MH she
couldn't get them and that's the reason
by the way I wasn't inour yeah yeah
that's that's the reason Joey didn't go
it was me it was me Conor uh didus and
Emily so we were all like League of
Legends fans and we all stayed up at the
same time to get tickets for the World
Finals months ago and then within like.
one second they were gone they were gone
like you you we had like we had like Ed
this to the like almost like the MC
everyone's like okay press refresh now
and then it was like you're in a queue
of uh 7,000 people yeah they were they
were all gone they were all gone uh
within like I don't know how keep up
with those we had to we had to we had to
use clout to get tickets like this is
the knew a guy knew a guy yeah this is
the first time that I've ever used kind
of like my connections and my internet
con which I hate doing I I [__] hate
doing this can you give me Le Legend
tiets do you know who I am I gigger I I
[__] hate doing this but this is the
first time where if I did not if I was
like not in the position that I am in
now I do not know how I would get ticket
cuz I tried yeah we tried every Avenue
we could because uh we you know we we
didn't want to resort to this but
because we had no other choice don't
want to resort to this I don't like I
you know I didn't like doing it to be
honest you just summon my final form
yeah it depends on like how close I am
with someone and like you know cuz if
they're like you're good friends with
them you be like hey man can I can I get
yeah sure if you don't really know them
it's like I don't want to have to like
oh someone something I don't want have
to use my clout to get it yeah it also
feels bad like yeah but you you know
there's nothing wrong with being like
hey I'd like to go you guys you guys
would you how do you feel about that L
how do you feel about that how does that
make you feel are you receptive to
that hey I I I I put in my hours I went
on the official League of Legends Tik
Tok stream what there oh yeah wa what
yeah I I I i' met Raz through doing a
jump my jump King event where he was a
commentator on it and uh I I I was a
huge fan of like League of Legends so I
knew him oh well you have to explain I
assume this guy's like a League of
Legends comment League of Legends
commentator uh and I always thought he
he was so [__] cool uh and then when
he was commentating on this event with
me I was super stoked he was super super
nice and uh we ended up talking and then
uh I asked him for tickets to the New
York thing yeah and he managed to get me
them and I was like dude thanks man
appreciate it and then I I didn't ask
him this time we have someone else uh we
got tickets and then he messaged me
while I was there like do you want to
come on the on the stream I was like
what
and he was like yeah just come on over
so I come on over and I'm talking and
sitting there and I'm having to talk
with this other Pro and I'm like I'm not
a pro by the way I'm just here to say
things but it was fun it was nice and I
appreciate him you know inviting me on
it pled in my hours see yeah and you
work on and yeah and I mean like the
highlight of the event for me
unfortunately was probably just the
opening act yeah the opening act was the
best part there was like fireworks and
[__] I kind of sad that it was just 15
minutes I kind of wish it was like 30
yeah it kind of sounds like the Olympics
it it is cuz like the opening ceremon
it's kind of like the uh it's kind of
like the risk you take with buying
sporting events right which is
unfortunately like the two times I've
been to a League of Legends World final
basic career uh it's just been a
complete stomp right so it just ends
super quickly yeah it just ends super
quickly and one of those times my the
team I was supporting was the team that
got stomped which was just like like it
it was like double whammy of just like
oh it
my team just sucks and there was nothing
to cheer for in this entire like 3our
event that I was there for but hey the
opening act was really fun and yeah cuz
the game was too one-sided to the point
where it it just wasn't fun right yeah
uh there was
literally there was no
tension the everyone was rooting for the
team that was winning as well so
everyone was roooting but even in the
last game everyone was kind of like
stopped rooting as much they were like
yeah it's kind of you already killed him
it it was it was really fun though I
definitely want to go again what did you
think of the stadium experience like the
kind of like atmosphere it was really
cool kind of kind of hard to watch
though actually cuz you're like turning
your head to like look at the big screen
but and also cuz we were in Korea I
realized I was like damn I kind of miss
hearing all the commentating in English
and having their Insight oh cuz all the
commentating was in Korean it's all in
Korean in the stadium so I'm just kind
of having to watch it and make up my own
thoughts which is fine but I mean I like
it sheep when they have no one to follow
well well that's just like it really
cool though yeah yeah that's just every
sporting event right because you you go
to a football match and you're like oh
[__] I can't where are the commentators
on the football match well football
football I felt like it is I don't know
it's different football energy is way
different to that energy I felt like I
thought you think so yeah I think okay
well I think there's just a different
energy in terms of the place that you go
to also the audience is very different
yeah the audience for League fans are
not like foot and football fans the
football fans will just start chatting
he's a [__]
then you're like I'll join
in there are so many like weird [__]
football jums like he's aedo he
AO and it's just like
normalized damn you didn't have to go
that
hard the whole like you know I remember
distinctly that like if they ever get
close to the goal everyone stands up and
it's just now it has this really
thunderous noise to it great [__]
love football games man it's just a
different yeah I feel like they're like
people who watch football are almost
like professional Watchers of of sports
what what are you what are you talking
about like I think people professional
reaction channels like people who people
who go to watch League of Legends are
not really Stadium goers generally right
they're not people who go to stadiums
they don't the atph yeah other than for
like one-off events whereas people who
go to watch football they have season
tickets they go every week you know they
are they are very very in the know of
like Stadium kind of Vibes and it makes
a different experience funny because I
remember when uh I remember there was
like some controversy uh controversy on
when League of Legends the world
championship was set in America and what
happened is one of the Korean teams was
facing an American team and when the
Korean team went like was introduced the
American audience booed
them and they American respon and they
got so much flag for that but like I'm
actually going to defend the Americans
because it because I'm like okay yeah
okay respect a good player respect all
teams but it's a [__] sporting event
all right you should be allowed to boo
you should be allowed to boo if you like
I I can't imagine like this is like the
test thing you could do in an English
football match like yeah booing booing
is like the least offensive thing that
happens yeah in English football match
or just football matches in Europe in
general we're going to [__] War you
know wor I think it makes really
compelling stories as well like having
having someone be booed and then maybe
they come out on top and you know maybe
they went over Theory yeah I think
there's I think that you should be
allowed to boo and cheer but the one
thing I I that I hate the most about uh
being in kind of uh more so that I've
realized Asian kind of stadiums I
haven't been in Japan much but when I've
watched them they they just make no
noise for the team they don't care about
which I feel like almost more offensive
because like oh my God you know in the
stadium right T1 the Korean team the
most popular team in the world come out
it was Kore it was Korea versus
China this guy is he's screaming at his
lungs of commentator he's introducing
the Chinese team he like and we have
China and then quiet no one makes
[__] noise and I feel like that is so
insulting so not even give them any
vocal it was it was worse it was like
the I don't know how well this
translated on the broadcast but I
remember when they introduced the
Chinese team there was a second silence
and then uh yeah yeah yeah lit literally
dead for second you know what if I was
on stage I think I would prefer the
booze I would prefer being booed rather
than having the pity clap of just like
yay yeah a couple of people clapping
sounds like horses [__] people don't
even care enough to give you an emotion
they don't even care enough about you to
to give a [__] it's it's pretty close in
Japan as well when I went to go see a
baseball match like because the stadium
is like perfectly split up so one side
of the stadium is like one of the teams
and the other side yeah the away team
and then one of them is the home team
and at the time were
te I
justed but it
Wasa the same home team comes on
everyone's standing up [__] shouting
spinning their towels around just being
like yeah let's [__] go moment the
away team comes on everyone just sits
down and just kind of looks at it's so
insulting dude I mean come on every now
and then someone be like
yeah yeah I mean like this it's it's a
sporting event let's have some [__]
rivalries in there and let's like just
acknowledge that there's rivalries there
at least acknowledge the en as long as
long as it stop you know doesn't go
further than booze you know I think it's
all all in good fun yeah exactly you
know it's you know as long as it's just
like little you know tongue and cheek
playful it's a sporting event we know
it's a sporting event that's I love
that's why I love fighting games
Community they talk mad trash boo they
cheer it's so fun to watch boy some milk
to me to me the that's why the fighting
in community seems so fun because they
seem like the right level of toxicity
yeah they're like they're all super into
it and they're all
in a way that I think really translates
to the viewer experience you really care
about these
stories everyone around you is so into
it and that that really feeds off like
you feed off of that and that's really
important to have that in sport yeah
totally I think it's why football has
been so uh sort of like dominant in in
like Europe and other places you know in
like South American stuff cuz it's just
it's such a passionate thing uh booing
and cheering it's all part of the
passion yeah cuz you know we did have
this world championship in Korea so
there was like a home team there that
people were going to cheer for and that
that was just like that's why I'm
excited for because next year it's in
Europe and oh next year in England yeah
and Europe European fans are well
they're they're they're pretty Rowdy
they are probably the most Rowdy crowds
I think in terms of sporting events yeah
yeah yeah the worst tourists yeah we're
the worst tourists but we make for some
of the funnest sporting events I feel CU
like in I don't know if I spoke this on
the podcast when I went to watch I
watched I watched uh a very big game of
of uh basetball
in La I watched it was like one of the a
key game between the two best teams at
the time the LA Lakers and Celtics I
think I think they're still the best
teams or very good teams I don't know
but one thing I found really weird is
that they don't chant themselves there's
a there's a speaker playing buildups to
chant to egg the crowd on to chant yeah
oh Japan's the same yeah
go like it would keep like it would keep
like in like telling them hey hey chant
defense defense but it would I was my
head I was like this is so weird I'm
sitting here I'm like why why sced Che
why do you guys have to be cute this
doesn't happen in Europe everyone just
goes they just start they just don't
shut up you go really obnoxious yeah you
go to local they you go to local matches
and I don't know how everyone in the
stadium just knows every chance that
there is I think I think they just
figure it out it's not just a chant
either it's always like the ones I've
seen online is like one guy starts the
chant and then there's like a call and
response thing that happens and
everybody knows the words perfectly
knows exactly the timing of the class
have you seen those there's a few videos
of guys who start the chant it's really
cool he like all right watch this and he
starts chanting and everyone joins in
within like 30 seconds it's really cool
I remember I saw him which just like
just one dude just like just holding the
phone he's like I'm going to start the
Chan just stands up and he's like what
do we think of blah blah blah and
everyone's like
[__] it's so fun that's like it's great
I love that [__] yeah it's it's good fun
I I really hope that you know we don't
we don't get rid of that in in all
sports yeah I I would like I would like
to see that translate to Esports cuz
Esports unfortunately bunch of [__]
Gamers we're a lot of introverts you
know we we we like going to League of
Legends events and other Esports events
they know how to cheer right they know
how to like make noise but you know they
don't know how to [__] talk yeah yeah
they don't know how to [__] talk which I
think I I mean it's it's it's not
encouraged and it's also not encouraged
which I think is like a huge part like I
think like guys you can do it behind the
keyboard but in real life well even then
they're like don't be there uh I I
forgot what I was going to say I had a
point and I totally forgot it uh [__] me
okay I mean they like legal Legends is
toxic enough online oh I was going to
say like but like Le has done a
fantastic job they have like literally
have writers to craft the narratives to
to like basically you know there's a lot
of story lines happening but they have
to pick out stories and like kind of
sell the audience on them uh and it's
something they've been really really
successful with and really good at uh
well that's just
sporting yeah yeah but I feel like it
happens almost because of the way that
Esports is structured where there are a
bunch of people uh we don't see them
physically uh we only see them on the on
the rift under a screen name we don't
really get like much of a connection
with the players yeah uh other than like
one or two very famous players and
because the rosters are to always
changing it's really hard to like find
like hear about players and know what's
happening yeah and so leag did they
really done a really good job at like
kind of picking out these stories
humanizing the people and kind of
telling you the story as it goes and as
it's unfolding they they change it which
I think is really smart whereas in
football there's like a bazillion
commentators and and pundits and people
on the YouTube channels saying their
thoughts so there there isn't really a
need for narrative as much like
officially like they're just people just
make up their own uh and that's pretty
successful doing that I think one of the
big advantages that the league Esports
has right now is one it's been like
going on for so long but two because
it's going been going on for so long now
that there are so many plays in like the
kind of like League ecosystem that have
just been around for really really long
time we're getting there we're getting
there the I think League of Legends on
average is like uh much older now uh and
also is one of the oldest Esports scenes
in general like the people who are in it
are are generally like late 20s now
right average I think May which is crazy
to say the average age of e League
Esports I think yeah it's it's kind of
cool I I mean I like that I like that
we're getting rid of this notion that
you have to be like a certain like
really really young that's rocket League
no that yeah average age of someone most
League of Legends players are between 21
and 20 oh no that's no that's not
professionals uh go back go back I think
you had something though yeah you had
something before go back it rocket it
was rocket league but it also said
League rocket League 21 according to
Esports chart I I contrast the average
Asian League of Legends in CS is 25 and
26 respect yeah which is a lot older
just because they're a lot they're
already we're already too old to be yeah
yeah yeah exactly we're too we're too
far gone God damn well it's it's it's
cool because like you know that that
means you have time to emotionally
invest yourself in some of these bigger
players uh I mean obviously when we were
there the most famous League of Legends
player of all time was playing Faker and
Sydney who knows nothing about League of
Legends at all was just like oh why why
is everyone hyping up this Faker I don't
[__] get it like it's like sounds
dumb sounds [__] dumb and then she
saw like Faker pop off in like one of
the games when he was like fake of the
goat one Ving and Sydney just turns to
me and she goes I get
it and I was like yes that's what I'm
talking about Sydney yeah yeah but uh
yeah it was a lot of fun as well uh
unfortunately there is a downside to all
of this oh no what just just like the
sacrifice we had to make so after
watching League what do we do the first
thing we want to do is uh go to a this
is actually like the highlight of my
trip to Career actually this really fun
yeah we uh me Connor darus and Emily we
go to a PC Cafe and we just stay up till
3:4 a.m. playing legal [__] awesome
and oh my God I have I cannot remember
the last time I had so much fun gaming
like so good just you can order noodles
to your seat and the noodles were so
fire it was so goddamn good you can get
coffees you can get teas you can get
drinks I'm not even mad I'm just
disappointed so we we we had to get some
leag Korean accounts which was kind of
hard to do we man to get them and then
we we we were playing some games
together it was really fun yeah and it
it just reminded me like it just made me
realize how much I missed gaming when
you have your Bros next to you
physically oh dude land parties are
always the best like there is nothing
that compares to a land party yeah for
sure yeah not the same otherwise it just
it was so reminiscent it brought me back
to like my University days where me and
the boys were just up till 3:00 a.m.
playing League some of the most fun I've
had in a very very long time time and uh
the knock on effect they had was
unfortunately I was really wanting to
chase that high
again and got back to Japan had a moment
of weakness and I was like this is like
watching a friend relapse on drugs like
and I was like maybe maybe it's the same
maybe it's the same I had a lot of fun
playing League of Legends in Korea
loaded up uh my Japanese account and I
started playing League again and I just
I I finished like two games and I was
like I can't look myself in the mirror
again again I'm not your dad but I am
disappointed in you like there was other
ways you know I think I would have just
preferred you to be a gacha gamer to be
honest with you like I didn't realize
there was something better than a gacha
player but turns out there he is but uh
yeah I will say PC bangs in Korea they
[__] hit different they're so cheap
as well yeah I bet yeah we went to an
expensive one and it was like it was
like 10 10 bucks for 4 hours yeah that
was that was an expensive one that's
nothing yeah that like this was the like
high like the the high tier ones cuz we
went to the official SKT PC Bang Yeah SK
T1 PC bang and I didn't realize this
until uh I went like a second time and I
looked at the specs all the PC there's
uh all the PCS there had like 407s like
graphics cards so they were like the top
high-end PC specs so of course you
expect like the uh you know better
Hardware as well but you can get really
really cheap PC bangs as well and still
pretty decent gaming PCs to go U and I
went to one with Sydney and uh to one
with Sydney I went to one with Sydney
cuz uh we were we were like oh let's try
playing uh Final Fantasy 14 again and I
was just like oh my God you're double
dipping double this is like this is like
I went back onto heroin and just I just
decided to try cocaine again as well you
know just why
not I get it I just like playing in a
playing next to your Bros playing next
to your part okay look I get that aspect
right but you shouldn't be double
dipping you know leave leave some space
in between pick one I just wanted to see
what the experience would be like cuz I
they say pick your poison they don't say
pick all the poisons at the same time
you know that's what I did basically
godamn it um yeah I I kind of really
really missed that culture uh because I
would I would love to spend more time I
think I would PC game more if I could if
there was like more PC internet like PC
bangs in Japan no yeah toally cuz it's a
totally different vibe uh playing next
to people uh and just being in an
environment this is going to sound so
sad being an environment where
everyone's gaming everyone's no like
it's definitely chill like it's way more
chill just see just seeing people just
like skipping lunch just ordering your
noodles and just like playing League
you're like oh I I want to be a
degenerate now I actually want to be a
degenerator the noodles are so good I
know what God's going to do when he goes
into
retirement hon honestly like perfect
holiday career it's it's you know you
know I'm sure it has like some we got to
we got to go back just for a weekend we
just game yeah me me me and con want to
go back and our holiday is just simply
going to be just wake up 10:00 a.m. hit
up the PC bang no life at for like 6
hours or something go get like a [__]
amazing Korean dinner or something like
that come back play a bit more games get
like you know have some drinks or
something have some drinks and uh sleep
and then uh repeat for like two days or
three days you guys are definitely game
more Gamers than I am that's for sure
dude there's just this it kind of like
captured that H I say I joke but I would
be into it as well it's kind of like
capturing that that the the summer break
when you're like 14 you're old enough to
like really enjoy video games now sure
uh and and you get just days or hours on
end to just waste and oh dude I remember
when I was like 14 13 and like I'd
invite my friends over during the summer
holidays and we'd we'd connect a bunch
of PCS together and do like a Civ 2 land
party all day like that was the [__] you
want to come with and play Final Fantasy
14 [__] come play come play League of
Legends with us come on with the with
the Bros God you know how hard I've been
trying to avoid playing 14 look look I'm
telling you you're going to like have
one day of it and if I go no that's the
thing this is the scary thing I don't
want to say yes because I know if I am
in that position especially with you
boys and we're playing 14 I am going to
be hooked and then I you will never see
a video from me ever again I'm not going
to play 14 I'm playing 14 if that
happens overly I'm playing 14 I just
like it's it it reignited in me
something I thought was like dead which
was the feeling of as Conor said the
summer break where you just take a
holiday which is like an adult holiday
where you you uh block a bit of time off
but instead of traveling doing something
exciting touching grass you just uh just
[__] no life this is DJ this is DJ
yeah was great that's fair that's it's
great um yeah that was basically our
Korean
experience literally the highlight of
the story was kind of was I'm not I'm
not going to not saying that there are
not other things in Korea which were not
like great um you know I went shopping
I've much prefer Korean fashion but um
yeah my my my highlight was just playing
League of Legends and that it was very
fun that sounds so sad but it was so
much fun I swear to God I respect it oh
God whatever it was very fun got to do
it again all right I'm going to take a
piss break this episode is sponsored by
Harry's boys do you feel like you have
too many unnecessary subscriptions
nowadays definitely like sometimes you
just subscribe to something and you
don't even really need it you know
something you actually do almost every
day it's shaving that's why you should
subscribe to Harry's I pretty much only
exclusively use Harry's you guys know
this I've spoken about this on many
occasions uh it's pretty much the only
razor I want to use in fact I don't have
any uh razor blade blades from Harry
right now and I am waiting holding
because I don't dare use any other razor
that's how much I like the shave that
Harry's gives me with Harry's you get
high quality German engineered blades
right to your door every order saves you
money compared to that Big Brand most
guys are used to buying get them as low
as get this $2 $2 $2 per blade but only
by going to harris.com trashtaste you
know what haris doesn't only make
raisins they have great skin care
products to compliment your great shave
as well guys absolutely a smooth shave
shouldn't be rough on your wallet the
trial set is $133 of value for just $3
at harry.com taste it includes a five
blade German engineered razor weighted
handle fing shave gel and a travel cover
so get a subscription that saves you
time and money with Harry's get started
with a $13 trial set for just $3 by
going harry.com traste that's harris.com
traste for a $3 trial set the episode
okay boys I want to bring up something
an anime topic all right that's right
wow I know
wow but this one is this one I'm
actually excited for because D Don just
got announced for an anime holy [__] I'm
so [__] hyped I just saw that as well
because it's science S I know dude what
it's science s who's that it's uh
[__] what's his name the
animation uh or if the
sorryy Bas basically basically the weird
studi yeah are doing D Don and the
trailer looks sick as [__] I haven't
seen the trailer yet dude
yeah I actually got the chance to read
the first few chapters of Dandan on
stream and it is wild it's so good so if
you don't know what Dandan is I believe
it's a Shonen Jump Jump Plus Jump
Plus uh and it's from one of the editors
no not editors but assistants of the
chainsa Man author tatki
Fujimoto and I don't know what was going
on in that studio when he was making
like chainsaw man or whatever or
whatever manga they were working on
together but every artist or every
author that's come from that studio has
just made like the like the weirdest
bang mang his assistants don't miss yeah
legit no one on that team has missed so
far cuz the other the other assistant uh
was um was he the guy who made um H
Paradise H's Paradise oh wow yeah yeah
so they all come they all came came from
the same stacked group of I know they
don't miss me yeah I really enjoyed
house Paradise yeah I did too I did too
and I think you really like donon as
well cuz absolutely [__] wild
especially if that studio is making it I
I'll I pingpong the animation is one of
my favorites it's like from the first
four devil man crybaby I also love devil
man crybaby I'm trying to remember the
[__] director's name um what's what
the [__] his name m
m [__] masaa yuasa masaki masaki yasa
masaki yasa yeah that's it yeah that's
it that's it yeah I don't know if yuasa
is directing this this one but it's from
his Studio yeah it's from his Studio s
uh so most most recently I actually saw
the uh I actually seen a few episodes of
the Scott Pilgrim anime that's oh the
first episode of that yeah yeah it's
it's good was weird I I I it's weird but
I I kind of [__] with it I thought it
was an interesting take just saw a lot
of people on Twitter arguing about it
yeah I I I I didn't know about like the
arguments or the controversy around it
so I went to to it completely
blinds um and I don't know what I was
expecting and I don't know whether I
liked it or not
I I mean I've only seen the first
episode it's hard to discern whether I
like it or not but I think I'm going to
like it I don't know that it is weird
also saw that Miami wouldn't La it as as
anime yeah which is dumb that's that to
me is dumb they said it wasn't intended
for the Japanese audience yeah and
that's how they decide of Something's
anime if it's for the Japanese audience
which is bizarre cuz Japan would be like
what the [__] what are you talking about
the weirdest mental gymnastics uh I've
seen yeah they'll do everything to just
say shit's not anime I don't know why
yeah they were like they were like oh
there must be something in here oh it's
uh it wasn't made by Japanese people
actually it's got a Chris Evans in here
which makes it for white people yeah no
like this Scott Pilgrim uh takes off is
an anime it was made in it was animated
in Japan it was storyboarded by Japanese
people people working it was basically
an all Japanese tee uh and you could
tell that because one of the biggest
things that bothered me about
uh about it was the lip flaps just
didn't match and I it was so obvious
that the recordings was done at at
different times from when the lip flaps
were like finished because this must be
how like Japanese people feel I don't
know like like well in Japanese anime
generally the lip flaps don't always
match up they're not not nearly but
they're also basic enough where it even
if they don't necessarily match up it
still feels more natural I guess yeah it
works I don't know how it works but it
weirdly works but they don't they don't
really care about the flaps having to
match perfectly but we very much we do
care yeah and I didn't think I would
notice it until I started noticing it
and I then I couldn't stop noticing it
well now that you've said that I didn't
notice it while watching it and now I'm
going to so thanks for that yeah it was
it wasn't like every time but it just
like sometimes it would just like be
like a tiny bit off or something i' be
like ah this is what it's like watching
originally dubbed anime I guess this is
why I had a really hard time playing
Final Fantasy 16 in Japanese because
they lipy synced it to the English voice
acting oh so when I was playing it and I
saw the cut scenes I'm just like [__] I
can't concentrate on this because they I
can read the lips and they're saying
something else to what I'm hearing and
it's so offputting I remember watching
scottt Pilgrim the movie and I thought
it was pretty good but then on Twitter I
keep seeing this thing about him dating
like a 17-year-old or something and I'm
like I don't remember that my knives was
17 she
was I think she was she was in high
school right that was that was the whole
that I guess so yeah yeah that was the
whole thing yeah I just don't remember
that being a big
deal I just remember watching it and I
was like I guess it's when did when did
Scott belgam come out like the the
original movie cuz um 2010 yeah 29 2010
yeah holy [__] that was a long time oh
my God that was 13 years ago a good
movie yeah I I thought it was an amazing
movie it still is like one of Ed right I
think it's I think this was on my 3x3 I
think uh for Toronto 22-year-old Scott P
A Bas play for un he is dating knif CH
17 I do I totally forgot that yeah I
think the thing about the new Scott
Pilgrim anime that I couldn't get my I
couldn't fully invest into I guess was I
think I realized I really really [__]
like the film but also I think I'm
perfectly satisfied with the film yeah
you had much and yeah yeah and Scott
Pilgrim takes off goes like a completely
different direction to the film it like
gives more more time for to explore each
like evil X and whatever and actually
less time with Scott Pilgrim uh which is
I think a big thing that people were mad
about which is uh at least where I've
gotten to Scott Pilgrim is barely in it
at all it's always a gamble isn't it
when you have like a new adaptation of a
show that is you know highly praised
beloved and people expect the story to
go exactly in that same direction and
then when they do you know they flip the
dime on and they're like actually we're
going to go in a slightly different
direction then people are like why why
why would you try and fix something
that's not broken theime is very highly
reviewed though yeah it's it's it's it's
it's interesting definitely I I I think
it's it was just weird where I was
watching it and I was like I guess I'm
enjoying this but I think I'd rather
just rewatch the movie I was like I have
I have my personal emotional attachment
to the movie and this is going like a
completely different direction and I was
like uh maybe I'm just not maybe I just
wouldn't be a fan of the comics I don't
know if this is more faithful to the
original
think the re really like the mie was
Theory but just of
edar I think that was the reason why I
really really [__] like Scott Pilgrim
um and this has a bit of quirkiness to
it but nothing that really compares to
the crazy [__] that Edgar right did
that's always scary though isn't it like
cuz you know I'm kind of feeling the
same way about the upcoming uh avatar
the Last air bender series like the live
action series the Netflix one yeah
because it's yeah they're doing a proper
like not with [__] Sham this time uh
well because the [__] shamalan live
action is the only thing we had and that
was the worst thing in the planet why do
you to remake it I don't get why why are
we remaking it I think it's just cuz for
a lot of people it's extremely nostalgic
and people actually want to see like I
don't know if people are asking for it
but I think I don't want to see yeah but
I think that I think the creators of the
series of the original animation wanted
to actually do like a proper live action
they wanted to like bring it back in a
way that they'd be happy with I would uh
I would be down for it if it wasn't
following the original James Cameron
story line because I think the weird
thing about Avatar for me is wait wait
James Cameron oh we're talking about
different avatars yeah yeah yeah wait
what are we talking about we're not
talking about the blue people Avatar
we're talking about Avatar The Last
Airbender wait I was like hold up wait
wait wait wait that's why I was like
making an avatar TV show what I thought
they were already making four films of
this shito was bro was cooking on 5
minutes figing out what to say that took
me a second I'll be
like s off about
this why would they make a TV series
about already a liveaction movie that's
what I was trying to like get my head
around when cuz you were like oh they're
making an avatar TV series that made
that's why I'm really worried I'm like
yeah yeah I can understand why you're
worried I'd be worried as well if they
were making James Avatar James Cameron
Avatar TV series but I was about to like
defend it because I was like Avatar has
an interesting world that does God no
I'm talking about the last air bander
[__] Jake Sully bro yeah you know I
think Jake Sully would be fine if he was
an Earth Bender y I can't I can't wait
to see Jake Su in live
action no no they're remaking uh
Avatar oh God to be fair we probably
should have said that I did say that he
justen you said Avatar you didn't say I
definitely said last day okay I didn't
know they were making well didn't didn't
they already make a liveaction movie of
this yeah the shaman movie and it was
one of the worst rated movies like of
the 2000s uh so in my head in my head
I'm like I don't want I feel like it
just doesn't need a live action to be
fair but then I said that about one
piece it was very to be fair I did watch
the uh the trailer for it cuz they
released the trailer for the new one it
I mean obviously it looks so much better
than the Sham movie like not even a
question and but I am like like kind of
keeping a healthy amount of skepticism
to it as well because this is like one
piece has like the one piece live action
was the double-edged sword I think it
proved to audiences that liveaction
animations could work and now I'm just
like and now there's a scramble to like
remake it's one diamond on a top a pile
of dog [__] you know I mean it was the
proof of concept that all they need was
one working example you know what else
is also a pro pro the concept this year
just making original [__] like original
movies have been ring it this year it's
been such a good year for like if you
are a Marvel and [__] dog [__] Disney
hater which I am um I'm so happy have
original movies been crashing it this
year I Oppenheimer I already know
Oppenheimer Bobby Bobby original
although although I I the concept of the
film is original so I'll give it that
you know we it's an original story the
mon film came out although it wasn't I
thought it was a bit long that it's done
really well uh there's a few other
movies this year that have done really
well but generally like a lot of these
big
Productions that would only ever do well
have not been doing not not so well yeah
which uh it's nice to kind of feel like
it's kind of changing a little bit I and
it's just showing that hey I think
audiences now I think we're they're
tired of remakes I think we're tired I
think as a collective audience we are we
just want new ideas we're not well
especially after all the [__]
liveaction Disney remakes as well it's
like I think that was the real nail this
year we've had the [__] Little
Mermaid remake uh you know and and even
then the original stuff feels so um uh
like regurgitative we had the Pinocchio
remake come out pin was pretty good oh
really I didn't see it it's like a
totally different uh retelling of
Pinocchio wait they did a remake of
Peter Pan um this year what isn't that
isn't that uh like one of those like
garbage M pet Pan and Wendy i' never
even heard the [__] okay side cuz nobody
gives a [__] uh what I did watch that
was uh very good and original and Anime
Pluto watch Pluto oh oh you finished it
yeah I finished it oh [__] only like two
episodes in uh really yeah I [__]
loved it I think it's probably favorite
anime I've watched this year oh dude
it's it's man he doesn't it's so [__]
good and I know nothing about Astro Boy
uh I I didn't even know that was
supposed to be Astro Boy until I
finished it yeah that's the but that's
what was so smart on urasawa when he was
riding Pluto is that he made sure that
you don't have to know anything about
Astro
Boy and and you you want to know
something like Pluto is probably like
uh you know it's it's a lot of common
consensus that Pluto is one of his
weakest Works what and right right it's
that or Billy
bat both amaz and I'm like this is your
weakest fighter which I I I really liked
it I think the ending was a little
little bit rushed but the rest of it I I
really really liked yeah I mean I I
remember what seeing the first two
episodes of it I just such he is such a
master when it comes to Building A
Mystery
and suspense it was like the
pilotepisode was so good I just the
scene where they had this kind of like
sence of the Lamb kind of like interview
with like the robot that killed somehow
so it's it's kind of a Sci-Fi world
where robots are in human society and of
course robots can't kill kill humans uh
except for one robot that has proven to
be able to kill humans in the past and
have like the Silence of the Lambs kind
of like interview with him [__] love
that character and that was such a that
was such a like an interesting character
study right he's just so good at writing
the most interesting like villains as
well like cuz like I don't know how he
cuz like you know Monster obviously
Johan is like an amazing example of it
but even you know the robot character in
Pluto like he wrote he wrote monster
yeah he wrote monster I didn't know that
yeah he wrote he did monster 20th
century boys yeah which are like
considered so yeah that's what you're
going up against oh [__] this man this
man is go he is the goat but like you
know he's so good at writing not only
just like interesting and multi-layered
villains but just villains that you it's
it you can take time with getting to
know and I don't know how he does it
like and this is one thing I've always
been like extremely uh fascinated with
and have so much respect for mystery
writers and stuff like that is that like
the really good mystery writers are able
to build up this mystery in a nice slow
easy to process way without it spoiling
anything yeah yeah there was such like
faith in you as the audience to to be
engaged as well that they didn't it
didn't have to go crazy right away it
was very willing to like allow you to
kind of just be like hey here's a little
bit of what's going on he sprinkle just
enough hints to get you hooked where
without spoiling a large majority of why
he like liked it he's so good at that in
an age where a lot of anime kind of feel
like it's just kind of rushed rushed
together Samy and almost unintentional
uh everything felt very very intentional
in this show that every single he
doesn't waste yeah every part of the
show just felt amazing and I really
really enjoyed it and uh please watch
Pluto if you haven't it's amazing it's
definely I know I don't know where would
rank but it's definitely like one of my
it's going to be I already know one of
my favorite anime of the year uh cuz I
think one thing I love about how he
introduces story is that he's one of the
few people who you can be like really
invested in this like main like a plot
line and then I don't know where he
would just like switch to a different
character and you're like why the [__]
would I give a [__] about this character
who is he why does he matter and then
you get invested into this separate
story line and you're like oh [__] I'm
invested in this and then at the end
he's like actually this is why this
relates to the first story and you're
like holy [__] 20th century boys was
like nothing but that and it was done so
incredibly well like every character as
you said every character and everything
they said everything they did had some
kind of built up to like a grounder
story line and oh my God he's so good
he's so [__] that's why he's the go
and it felt like a complete package
which I I really feel like I've been
missing a lot in anime lately where I'm
so used to watching half a season and
then it it gets delayed or whatever and
because the conditions are are Dreadful
right now but uh you know it really felt
like this one this show had a time to
cook really let it like it came out when
it was ready I mean the mar came out
quite a while ago I think so they've
been they've been working on this for a
long long time it's a pretty old series
um but I've heard that I've heard that
if this one does well which go so does
do well 2003 came out uh they they would
like to adapt more of n's Works 20th
century boys when getting an anime of
20th C Bo are able to adapt his
magnumopus in my opinion which is 20th
century boys I will literally come
that's not a euphemism I will just come
I I I literally I will actually watch
anime if he does that even Billy bad as
well which is another fantastic UD manga
like if if they do a good adaptation of
that which might be a little bit harder
just because a lot of the characters are
not human in that uh but yeah people
need to read more uros [__] and like so
underrated I I like it when concepts are
explored like decently sometimes they
they they some shows try to talk about
morality and it comes from a point that
I just I really am like okay sure yeah
like hard to relate to oh yeah not even
hard to relate to but just it feels like
the the Nuance the show is struggling to
express the idea like fully uh and it
really felt like this one kind of nailed
every single kind of like moral
conundrum it was trying to present to
you as the audience I really enjoyed it
so please watch Pluto because I want
more of his shows cuz I don't want to
read it and watch monster as well also a
great anime Monster's also F I didn't
know who's monster moner great monsters
are just too slow though to it's kind of
hard to recommend it's a bit of a slow
burner I think epis and 30 of them are
very
slow I mean read the Manga manga's
probably better but read 20 Cur Bo read
I should read it should read boys isn't
just my favorite manga I think it's just
my favorite story that's ever been
written uh genuinely like it's I can't
disagree with you on yeah I mean it's
it's it's like from a critical
perspective it's an absolute Masterpiece
but also for all the ideas it explores
it just like really personally related
to me as well um even the live action
was good for 20th century voice it's so
weird because he cuz he's a musician
right so music was like a big kind of
like aspect in 20th century boys and
like the fact that he just wrote a song
in a mar
yeah he wrote he wrote his own song for
a manga and I'm just
like I respect it but how how where the
[__] did you get this idea fromi and
inio oano are the only two people who
can do that and they're both goats yeah
yeah exactly so highly highly recommend
Pluto that's definitely going to be
watch onet one of the top anime of this
year as well I feel not enough people
are talking about it either which is the
saddest I haven't seen anyone cuz I mean
I think it's cuz I think it's CU jju
kais is stealing the spot right now with
in many ways in many ways good and bad
yeah have you seen the Twitter stuff no
all the animators being like this is
hell yeah oh yeah but they've been
saying that for a while right yeah no
but like really bad now bad which I okay
here's the thing I don't know if if this
is just here's here's the sad part I
don't know if this is uh a new
development or if you know if this is
something that we've probably that has
probably always been a thing and people
are just now more vocal about because
they more animators on Twitter you know
it's Yeah Yeah the more animators on
Twitter and it's also a really big show
yeah yeah I would like to hope it's not
the ladder but you never know I think
if in the world is as such that it's
very sad if this was like another eai
anime and the anime was like um this is
[__] I can't do this anymore be like
okay well all right I don't want that
dog sh Show anyway yeah uh but you know
I think CU it's a show that everyone is
really talking about and then hearing
that all the animators are really
struggling it's like okay
oh this is kind of [__] up also [__]
up that it takes a show like this to
people to kind of care yeah it's [__]
up and I think you know the Silver
Lining is that because I guess J is so
big because this thing has been
prevalent in the anime industry for
[__] since the beginning of anime
basically um and it feels like now more
people are getting aware of it and more
people are talking about it than ever
before just because of how big jutu Kon
is and also the animation is absolutely
[__] batshit insanely good yeah uh in
this new season that I think everyone is
like jit is no longer M you have
to it's hard was before but I swear to
God it's so far beyond me I'm not going
to support a show that punishes
animators actually so all
right okay it feels it feels almost bad
like uh like fawning over the animation
and saying how amazing it is and then
equally knowing what is what is the
costen uh but [__] me it's so good and I
I hate that it's so good because I feel
so bad for these animators but and
everyone was like what can we do what
can they can they strike it's like I
mean uh I mean if you do then you're not
going to get a new episode string has
happened in Japan uh but it is very rare
yes and it's not very effective uh it's
yeah it's very debatable how how
effective it is in Jaan yeah um and
unfortunately because they're hiring a
lot of people online I think they're
just churning through that's the kind of
shitty thing right is that like it's not
this isn't really an issue that aage
watch what can the average is there
anything the average anime viewer can do
except for just be more aware of I think
I think the only way that it'll change
is if like the actual industry itself
just kind of does a top down reshuffling
of just how but that doesn't happen in
Japan because they love tradition I mean
it the thing is I think this goes beyond
just like the anime industry of course
that's like one example the
entertainment industry in general it's
just like you know it's one Japanese
work culture and expectation
and it's and it there needs to be a
change from a systematic level um I I
feel there's there's not so much the
average person can do which kind of like
sucks cuz you kind of feel helpless but
this issue runs really really [__]
deep yeah um totally but we got we got
good anime right
yeah
[__]
but hey Gojo is popping
off so funo was wild oh God is insane it
is actually you should watch it I mean
I've seen the gifts yeah oh yeah like
the animation I feel like it's been I
don't know
how each episode has been some of the
coolest [__] I've ever seen you know
yeah I I I I almost feel that I think
you said this to me off camera you said
that if if if we were doing anime fights
of the Year all the nominations would be
Jitsu k oh yeah the the best fight of
the year was is J Kon fighting against
itself yeah
it's it is shocking the only one who can
defeat me is me like when you watch an
anime it almost feels like normally
there's this natural like cycle where
it's it builds up and there's a one big
fight where there's a lot of like a lot
of crazy animation going on and then
you're like okay cool I can I can kind
of decompress and's like hey every
episode we up it you're like okay what
the [__] and every single you're like oh
my God okay Jesus oh my [__] oh wow holy
sh what it's it's it's just crazy yeah
and I heard like from the manga readers
that the biggest fight of the Ark isn't
even like close to here yet it's there's
there's an even bigger fight that's
coming and I'm like what we've had like
three four amazing Banger fights already
and then there's there's still more to
come all the animators just
like me I mean this might age poorly
because we don't know what the quality
of future episodes is going to be I
would just rather them delay it I'd
rather them just not release this uh if
it if it's costing this but obviously
there's no shot that's happening there's
no shot that's happening unfortunately
it's it's too big yeah I would rather
them delay it as well I think everyone I
think I 90 90% of people 99 would would
agree that they'd rather just the show
be done in in a correct way where people
aren't have feeling that they have to go
and complain on Twitter but they're also
going to if they want to get that result
right because they' be like I can't
believe they went on a month Hiatus what
the [__] at a good point too and like
this always going to be two sides of the
opinion on that so they can't win I
don't know if if you saw G but uh
Invincible uh it's after episode 4 of
this season 2 oh yeah it's going on a
hius really for until 2024 and people on
Twitter were like that's [__] up and
there was like tons of tweets doing
really well that were just kind of like
this what the [__] what's the point of
this right and then it it why are they
going on hi know uh I I think it's cuz
they to give the animators time I think
it's I think it's should to give I think
I I mean could you check this guy yeah I
I know first time hearing it I mean
that's good cuz I haven't started season
2 yet so and it does suck cuz you're
like man halfway through a season sucks
yeah you kind of wish that I would I
would have been completely okay with
them just delaying the whole season yeah
I kind of prefer the season being
delayed and getting it all in one go but
I understand um yep but yeah so it's G
on a bit of a break okay and it's like
people I understand now why shows are
very reluctant to do this cuz the
reaction was just like they were like
what the [__] why would you [__] do
that Midway so [__] up uh and it's
just kind of like sad cuz you're like I
think if you if you explain it in a way
audiences are receptive but sometimes
that just like now I want show now yeah
but have you considered the fact I don't
care and I just want the next episode
you which is shitty thing to do but it
happens yeah I mean I feel like a lot of
this can be offset a bit with better
planning I don't know I don't know I
feel like a lot of this uh we're not
part of the industry we're just
speculating at this point you know like
a lot of this I feel comes from like you
know someone high up top being like we
it would be nice to uh get our show out
in this schedule yeah and then the
people actually working on the show are
like this can't be done or this will be
done very very this poorly we would have
to like kill ourselves uh and then
somehow they deliver it and then the top
people are like we can do this again
let's let's keep doing it
so it's just like a kind of like a
negative kind of feedback loop where
nothing improves uh yeah as you said
that I think in order for anything to
change at this point you know whether it
be Western animation or the anime
industry like there just needs to be a
top down remodeling of just how the
system works so that it's fair for
everyone people don't complain as much
and we still get a good you know product
at the end of the day but hey easier
said than done it's not going to happen
anytime [__] soon unfortunately yeah
um but yeah unfort it feels like kind of
like uh bit of sweet to talk about how
good Jiu-Jitsu kaen 2 is just because we
know of the things going on behind the
scenes but still you know curious to see
what the rest of the season is going to
be like we'll see how it goes iess want
the most ironic case I've seen all year
Z 100 oh yeah Z 100 the show it's on
like it was like permanent Hiatus
indefinite Hiatus what yeah it only it
only got to episode 9 or something I
believe yeah yeah
yeah which like tell me the irony of a
show showcasing production issues
production issues apparently a ton of
the animators quit right or something
like they're releasing the rest in
December or something I think it's oh
they're releasing the rest in December
the rest is finishing by Christmas or oh
okay yeah yeah Jesus but it's been on
heus for quite a while now right a
couple months yeah okay I've said 10
okay so okay so it's not on they just
went they just took a [__] fat Hiatus
yeah which oh jeez which is like
interesting cuz I don't think we've ever
had like a mid SE hi us this long before
any show 86 oh yeah it's it sucks to uh
see this but hopefully this will maybe
like you know if if this kind of stuff
happens and if the audience kind of
isn't receptive to it and a lot of
people don't watch the because you know
a lot of people are going to fall off
because of this because you know they're
not going to they're not going to wait
around they're going to move on to the
next day hopefully that kind of feedback
gets to the executives who are making
these decisions who are trying to rush
things out they're like look the last
time we tried to rush this out it
[__] blew up in our faces let's let's
try and do this properly next time yeah
which is why it's great when we get like
a production like freen which is a
[__] Banger anime and has had like a
me to watch it it's so good it's it's
also I see a little porn of it is that
why do I see that on Twitter it's I I I
noticed this as well I I was going to
talk about this because I remember read
I remember reading the manga and I
thought my Twitter feed was weird I
haven't seen any of that [__] it it but
I'm not surprised the only the only
stuff I've seen in freerun is porn
really yeah which means that it's either
like an amazing amazing show or a dog
okay so so here's here's the weird thing
okay so um as like a manga reader fore
end I'm never reading the manga it's a
very like touching emotional show right
and it's its characters are definitely
not like let's say the fan service type
okay like a lot of like yeah you know
all of like basically all of the girls
in there uh you know they are very rare
I can't think I can't even think of a
scene where they are like even showing a
lot of skin like a lot of clothes they
wear like cover all of their bodies
can't really see their props it doesn't
the the story and the vibe of the whole
show doesn't really incite any of that
kind of like mentality in any way and
the story of the vibe as well because
they're really [__] squeezing this
[__] out very like emotional touching
tale so what freen has proved to me is
that it don't [__] matter about the
vibe at all if people want to lud
someone they the internet are going to
[__] do it all it takes is one artist
to be like this is a wholesome show but
that character's hot well it's like I I
didn't think the fish girl was hot in
Zelda but I saw a lot of porn of the
fish girl speaky yourself that's
she okay I'm sorry I'm I'm just being
honest but like yeah it is it is kind of
a weird phenomenon because we haven't
really seen examples of similar Vib like
that's kind of like people you know
looting Spice and Wolf which no one
really did because this because well I
mean I didn't see it because like and
it's because it's such a someone
definitely looted Spice and Wolf I mean
the only one who looted Spice and Wolf
was hakura himself for making Hollow
just naked for a lot of the show that's
the thing you know what's weird
sometimes now now I see if there was
like a fan servy show I never see any
like lude fan out of it right you know
what I mean now it's just like the anti
fan service shows Doan artists are like
playing the reverse yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah they are they are and I feel like I
don't know
the I I I feel like with freen there was
this one scene in the latest episode
where I okay there was like one I think
horny bait scene but it was just like
compared to other horny bait scenes it
was like very very tame um it was when
fre Ren like there was a shot where free
Ren had her feet just like
showing and artists are like yo it's
free real estate let's go show feet show
feet she showed her feet let's go let me
see her
feet like feet so much what's the deal
with feet I don't get it I wish I wish I
could understand isn't it the most
common fetish though in the world or
something uh don't know I think I
remember seeing something where bastard
oh my
God words in my mouth go I wish I got it
I wish I got it but I just so I could
understand the mind yeah I think I think
I read somewhere that like feet fetishes
are yeah I think feet fetishes are the
most common fetish it's it's called so
the technical term is called podofilia
oh my Lord they really they really
shouldn't have
why yeah yeah I'm a
poile oh he's a Potter yeah I can't
imagine that one caught on with
the feet
enjoy Naval fetishes body piercings
tattoos
gerontophilia uh underwear hair color oh
the intense sexual attraction that
younger men and women feel for older men
and women can qualify as oh cradle
snatching right oh cradle snat what the
[__] yeah feet is like the most common
yeah Feats the most common yeah I don't
I don't get it I mean I'm personally not
into it but that could be worse things
you're into what csil is a
fetish you get seual if you get bricked
up yeah if you get bricked up so is
boobs a fetish well I think cuz it's
like no that's just an instinct but
that's that's the thing right what what
counts as a fetish I thinks boobs n ass
could technically be a fetish but
they're so common place that we wouldn't
consider fetish think fetish is unusual
yeah I think fetish is something where
the the the Layman would look at it and
be like I don't really feel anything to
but then there'll be someone else to be
like no that's hot gratification is
strongly linked to a particular object
or activity of a body it needs to be
something super specific other than a
sexual other than the sexual organs so
do thy count as a fetish yeah okay yeah
that's a that's a fetish number two an
in in an inanimate object worshiped for
its supposed magic powers or because
it's considered to be inhabited by a
spirit I've never heard of this
definition of a I think I've i' I've
read that being used in that sense and I
was very confused cuz I was like huh H
what that's that's
weird but yeah uh I don't know why I
don't know why it is free Ren that all
the artists have chosen to uh I think
we've I think we've kind of grown up in
an age now where like when it comes to
the Doan community at least from how I
observe it as someone who's you know
followed it for a long time like when
you look back to like the 2000s or like
the 2010s right it was the obvious Doan
bait shows that would get the most do in
right where it's the shows that were
either just straight up sexualizing the
characters in the original story or ones
that kind of alluded to sexualizing the
characters but didn't necessarily go all
the way through now I feel people again
have played the reverse game where it's
like they look at the obvious looted
stuff or the ones that allude to it and
they go no but that's too obvious the
show is already doing it for us so let's
take the ones where the show doesn't
even hint at it at all and give people
what they might possibly want that they
can't get from the original show and so
I think that's why shows like freen now
are getting more looted than other L to
shows cuz like we never saw any doans of
like read off healer because the show
was already doing it for a lot of people
right like but free Ren is not the
characters are [__] also the characters
are [__] of course I don't [__] feel
anything suck but you know that doesn't
stop the fact that there were a lot of
people who watched that show and we're
like well you know the show is already
going all the way through so Doan
artists were like well there's no place
for us they've already done it for us
whereas fre is like they look innocent
but they are aesthetically pleasing
characters where if we put them in lwd
position
a lot of people might like it I don't
know that's just my observation as a
Doan uh professional I think it's the
implication you know yeah it's it
because I don't know it's it's weird
because I does it ruin the show I don't
think it does this isn't a complaint
this is not a complaint at all this is
this is merely just an observation see I
don't know because like I think I
mentioned this in an earlier podcast
episode but like I can't read doons of
shows I really enjoy oh yeah you did
mention that so like monari couldn't be
me monari like any of the shows that I
grew up with I can't read doans of it
cuz it just ruins my perspective of the
shows that I love so much Rob Pokemon
no
what speaking of fetish is there
something us where [__] did that come
from listen listen are you a furry no no
I just wanted to see how you'd
[Music]
react look if you're into it call but
that ain't me I'm not into it what about
vapore did you know
I'm just I'm just curious God OFA no
okay no no buone no no yeah
chansy that would be an interesting one
oh my God where do you
start oh we're going to
hell why are we talking about I don't
know I just thought it was [__] dumb
but I just thought about it but see like
that's why like the doans I always
enjoyed reading were the shows that I
had no personal connection to or
affiliate to from the original show so
like I had no problems reading like Oro
do because I don't give a [__] about the
original show or the original characters
so I don't care what position they're
put what you're saying is you maybe you
don't like the canonical breaks that the
Doan introduced it kind of ruins the
entire story I think so how did you guys
have you guys ever read I guess doans
are kind of like fan fictions I've never
read or kind of like fan kind of like
stories that have nothing to do with
let's say you know like hentai or
anything but just literally just like
let's say a fan story yeah do you enjoy
those at all have you ever had a point
where you're like damn the Cannon story
didn't give me everything I wanted to
and uh I I kind of went into like the
fan territory no because I'm like cuz I
also understand that that was that
particular manga artist or you know
writer's decision to do so and you know
I might not be satisfied with it but you
know at the end of the day I can just
move on to something else as well you
know like I'm not I don't think I've
ever read a series where it's been that
I've been so heavily invested into where
I'm like I want to see the best ending
for this and this is the exact ending
that I Envision and I hope the artist or
writer delivers and then it' be
something completely different usually
like with those kinds of stories I get
heavily invested into I'm satisfied with
the way it ends in some regard and if
there are ones where like I'm not
satisfied with it then I'm just going to
go well you know it wasn't exactly what
I had hoped for but I I still enjoy the
and you know I can just move on to
something else can you Google the most
famous fan stories i' I've love to know
examples of like what are some really
popular fan stories well wasn't like uh
wasn't uh what was it yeah 50 Shades of
Gray right 50 Shades of Gray was a
Twilight fan fic F fan fiction yeah it's
it's I've done it twice I've I've I
you've done it twice what do you mean
you've done it what do you mean you've
done it um you've written one no not
written one okay I was about to say I
guess no no no like cons assumed like
some fan some fanfiction out of some
dissatisfaction to like a main like
story line which ones are they yeah
could you click the article 10
successful books that yeah oh yeah yeah
let's let's check these out okay 50
Shade yeah obviously cyia bones love
hypothesis I don't know any of
these okay I do not know any of these
either go okay yeah don't know that
don't know that I don't know any of well
here's the thing I don't think we're
like the usual kind of like I don't
read that was fair that's fair I
mentioned like this book I was reading
once on trash tast I was nearly done
with it I had like I had like um not not
like 40 50 pages left in it yeah uh and
I was like yeah I'll talk about when I'm
done and I just never [__] finished
it this is like was it the abroad in
Japan
book I haven't started
yet but I was like man I I I think I
just don't enjoy reading as as much as I
I wish I did a manga I enjoy but even
then I I think I just too I don't really
enjoy reading that much I wish I did
that's fair I wish I wish I did cuz I
feel like why do you wish you did
because it feels like such a a vast uh a
vast untapped source of knowledge and
also like the world you can throw
yourself into uh so much more
imaginative novels and stories and I
wish I could kind of get into it but
sadly I can't yeah like I was saying you
like I there are two things that like
stick out to my mind in terms like
fanfiction F fictions I guess the first
one uh I remember being first time
watching evangelon being very very
dissatisfied with the ending right the
TV series end the TV series ending and
the end of AA mov ending as well this is
back in my point where I like [__]
hated AA right uh and I remember
discovering this dojan which I think is
like the greatest dojan of all time that
I've ever read it's called retake okay
where it's kind of like a reimagining of
the Evangelion ending that kind kind of
like ties in all all of the plot points
uh that cuz you know if you've seen AA
you know that there's a different appeal
to the end of evangelon then let's say
tying up all the plot points cuz half
the plot points just [__] they forget
about you know uh but it gives this was
before like 4.0 came out it gives you
like it gave you like it gave me
emotional closure for all of the
characters which the original series
didn't do and do you think that's why
unno made 4.0
he's like I see all I see people are
very dissatisfied with the ending I'm
going to make my own fan fiction of my
own show I don't think ano gives a
[__] I mean I feel like I feel like the
entire rebuild was just his own
fanfiction of it you know pretty much
pretty much and I remember the second
time I did this as well was the first
time I'm reading Love
Hina where you're like but what if what
if what if what if other girls had like
a nice happy ending yeah uh and that was
the last time I ever dipped my feat into
the world of Fanfictions okay but to be
fair like there was one show there was
one manga series that I think did that
in a really really cool way and it was
this manga called B like we can't study
or we can't something like that they had
a canonical like one of the girls like
you know getting the bag and you know
that was like the end of like that har
but then the author did a gigabrain move
and he released one more volume where he
gave a canonical ending to every single
love interest so that everybody would be
satisfied he n boss phoned it in Bossman
phoned it in Boss phoned it in but he
also gave everybody a satisfying ending
with one way or another and he was like
you know what I will not I will not let
the Doan artist take the bag I'm doing
this myself godamn it we we need one
winner in a harm anime or everyone's a
winner you know yeah what is [__]
participation award har look it didn't
matter cuz my favorite girl won
canonically so I was satisfied with it
but I was like you said all of them were
canonical well technically they weren't
he was just like this this was like a
what if scenario of like he picked the
other girls like he basically visual
noed it essentially sounds like copium
it's a I was absolutely copium but I
would also be huffing that same copium
if I was him as well like I can't
believe you didn't pick this girl I I
feel like I would be less invested in
Haram anime if I knew every girl was uh
going to have a happy ending you know I
feel like to me the appeal of Haram
anime is knowing that one of these girls
pick like a football team you pick a
pick a side yeah Haram anime is just
like Sports Anime in Disguise it's it's
the closest that anime fans come to
being toxic uh sports fans yeah
basically yeah yeah 100% you know that's
why uh but at the same time you're also
calling out every fan fig riter as well
in that sense then f i I will happily
say that I was in copium mode when I was
just like I just want to see different I
I I just like give me a crumb give give
me a Crum of cope right now because just
being like I just want to see Oscar
happy that's all I care about and I
don't care if I have to search through
the Deep crevices of fanfiction.net to
find that [__] why the [__] did you have
to call me
out oh God I know you well I know you I
did not need to be called out like that
all right well thank you guys so much
for joining this episode of trash taste
we're going to end it there hey don't
forget uh we got some brand new merch
right here that we're showing off right
now it's [__] is in the descri below
it's available for a very limited time
so make sure to grab look at that
illustration shirts button UPS long
sleeves we got everything make sure
check out insane I'm not kidding link is
on the screen right now also look at all
these patrons though wonderful patrons
abely wonderful wonderful people hey let
us know what your favorite fan fiction
is and your favorite fetish if you have
one whatever you want I guess we don't
get opening up that bag of w yeah
yeah please don't
[Music]
yeah that'll be the most uh yeah don't
write that down but hey if you like to
support us go over to our patreon
patreon.com trast also follow us on
Twitter send us memes on the subr and if
you ha our face listen to us on Spotify
we will see you guys all next week tell
me of also if you didn't know that James
Cameron was making an avatar live
action that'll be everyone all right see
you guys next week
[Music]
bye